[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUBJECT: The philosopher,
Ernest Becker,
in his book, "The
Denial of Death,"
says that the human
situation (LAUGHS)
is so terrifying,
when you really
consider the big picture,
that, to not go mad
would amount to another
form of madness.
Now, the philosopher,
Kierkegaard,
has an interesting definition
of the schizophrenic,
and he compares and
contrasts the schizophrenic
to the depressive.
Now, basically, he says
that the schizophrenic
is overwhelmed by
too much possibility,
that the schizophrenic is
privy to too much vision,
too much ecstasy.
He simply is overwhelmed, he
is flooded by an overbearing
amount of sense
impressions, impregnated
with so much meaning, with
so much signification,
that he is torn apart
by the simple fact
that there's no
possible way that he
can ride every single one
of those sense impressions.
He can't be here, and
there, everywhere.
The schizophrenic is torn
apart because he simply
is obliterated and is
not grounded in any way.
He's pulled in the
every possible direction
he could be pulled, unfiltered,
terrified, like a living
wake-walking nightmare.
The depressive,
on the other hand,
has the illusion that the
walls are caving in on him.
He simply cannot envision
a different situation
for himself.
The depressive is subject to
a failure of the imagination.
He is stuck with too much
entropy, too much gravity.
The here and now sucks, and
he cannot imagine another
possibility for himself.
In other words, the
world is caving in.
There is nothing but despair.
He is too grounded.
So again, the schizophrenic,
not grounded enough,
pulled apart by too
much possibility.
The depressive, too
grounded, too in his body,
cannot transcend his own weight.
It's a failure of
the imagination.
Two contrasts, two extremes,
loosely-defined, most of us
probably finding ourselves
somewhere in-between.
But nonetheless, an interesting
definition, and a creative
challenge to each
and every one of us.
How do we partake in
these beautific visions,
these ecstatic visions, and
nightmarish perspectives,
and leverage them, and try to
create life for ourselves that
is, at the very least, filled
with a little bit of grace?
[MUSIC PLAYING]